[Music]
welcome to cbs saturday morning i'm jeff
glor with michelle miller and belated
birthday girl
dana jacobson happy birthday thank you
be happy thank you and again a year-long
celebration we are celebrating all year
long
everyone roll right into the next
birthday why not i love it thank you
coming up this hour mining a rich vein
of humor you may not know his name but
author humorist and comedy writer simon
rich has found endless ways to make us
laugh from his work on snl and the
simpsons to his books and essays we will
meet him and see physical proof that
he's living out his childhood dreams
plus it is one of the world's favorite
foods certainly mine but what makes some
pizza rise above the rest we'll get a
lesson in how to make the perfect pie
from chef and author dan richard and
later the american buffalo was saved
after hunting nearly drove the animal to
extinction but that was just the
beginning we'll take you to montana
where native americans are continuing
the effort to restore herds of these
majestic creatures to their lands that's
ahead
but first up this hour a special report
ahead of next week's observance of
veterans day the tomb of the unknown
soldier is one of the nation's most
treasured and sacred sites this year
marks its 100th anniversary and an
extraordinary departure from tradition
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge reports from
arlington virginia
in the sacred grounds of arlington
national cemetery a white tomb rises
above the rest bearing this inscription
here rests in honored glory an american
soldier known but to god what makes the
tomb of the unknown soldier so powerful
for some families this is the only grave
that they had to visit back in the 20s
but even still today it's really an
incredible
place right on this crisp autumn day our
guide is the cemetery's historian
allison finkelstein this veterans day
marks the memorial's 100th anniversary
as a place of deep respect america has
changed the ways that it remembers the
war dead from
thinking about that grave is connected
to world war one to now thinking about
it as representing all of our nations
fallen throughout time next week an
honor reserved for presidents will be
available to all the first time in
decades that the public will be able to
walk out on the plaza gerald lowe who
coordinates major events at the cemetery
said there is no charge but online
reservations are required for november
9th and 10th when history gets personal
when we've seen the president in the
past
place the wreath at the tomb of the
unknown soldier that's the same location
where the public will be able to place
flowers at the time so there's a real
intimacy absolutely an intimacy not only
for your everyday american the american
public but anyone from around the world
after world war one the remains of four
unknown service members were exhumed
from four american cemeteries in france
the u.s army went to extreme lengths to
ensure that the unknown buried here in
the tomb was truly one that could never
be identified a highly decorated soldier
made the selection on october 24th 1921
sergeant edward f younger used a spray
of white roses to indicate his choice
and why is it so important that the
unknown can never be identified they
really wanted to make sure that
anybody
could connect with that soldier and that
he could have been of any race any
religion he could have been born in the
u.s or he could have been a recent
immigrant crowds swelled the streets of
france as the casket made its way to the
uss olympia for the transatlantic
crossing to washington d.c where the
remains lay in state at the u.s capitol
they actually opened the rotunda up to
the public and over 90 000 people came
to pay their respects and like today in
1921 the nation was tested not only by
armed conflict but reeling from the 1918
spanish flu the summer of 1919 there was
a lot of unrest across the country this
was a turning point in american history
in many ways
finkelstein said memorials evolve
connecting and reconnecting generations
through respect for service we hope it
is a place of unity and that's certainly
how it was intended when they created it
in 1921
for cbs saturday morning katherine
herridge arlington national cemetery
so much to learn coming up
in next on coming up next week on the
cbs evening news a special series ahead
of veterans day honoring our heroes
highlights the service and sacrifice
of america's military